[Music]
we were talking about um what doing a
show how have you so you you've been
like do you find it stressful
surprisingly not that stressful I enjoy
it a lot you were you stressed we to do
like we had to do so it was our schedule
was really bad um but to the point where
the third season I had two eye twitches
two different eye
twitches and I see your eye twitches and
raise you erectile
dysfunction soft serve
[Applause]
yeah um old Twitchy like literally two
different rhy I couldn't it was crazy
going to the point where I said toelle I
was like dude I can't get a bone and he
goes I can't either man
um he goes it's fine you just have to
take the laptop off your
lap he thought that was the only problem
we had he thought that he thought that
it was the gamma raay from the from the
laptops were getting into our
penises but in his case they
were cuz he apparently stopped using the
laptop he's like it's
back
okay and aren't gamma ray supposed to
make things bigger and angrier yeah I
don't know he
but
I've never heard the Q card man laugh
that hard that was amazing that was a
huge that was a big Hulk fan like he's
almost making fun of
you that's why Chappelle walked away the
wrong kind of laugh that's
right